we're getting major reveals meeting
scary moms and asking Chris Harrison for
sex advice oh good
Jill yeah all right it's time for roses
and Rosie hi you guys i'm lauren zima
we're recapping becca Gouffran season of
The Bachelorette and it is time to get
down in hometowns but Colton's not gonna
get down because he's a virgin okay
everybody
Oh what an episode it was I am drinking
red wine today because we don't have any
ice here in our office sorry I'm back
and we are gonna drink every time we
need becca to acknowledge that she's in
love with blake you guys tell me what
you thought was your perception of
hometowns a little bit shaded and jaded
by the fact that you know Becca's in
love with Blake she told us that last
episode this was the first time this
season that I've become very confused by
things that Becca said and I was very
unsettled tell me if you felt the same
anyway don't drink every time you're
confused because it starts off with
Garrett and Becca in his hometown and
Becca says the Garrett makes her want to
quote follow through the truth of him
why why it's know I'd like to show you
the place that turned me into the man I
am today
I'm staying quiet because we have a lot
of questions about the man Garrett is
today a lot of questions that we are
still gonna need him to answer once he's
able to do an interview I'm not judging
it I'm just saying I have a lot of
questions anyways and Becca is with him
on the farm I forget what state they're
in Idaho Iowa I think I'm not judging
I'm from the Midwest I just can't
remember what he said
Becca has a very strong reaction to
planting tomatoes we planted tomatoes
she was really excited about that I'm
confused
mm-hmm okay but Garrett did say he
wanted to plant a rosebush for her so he
could give her roses forever and that
was cute I got to give Garrett props he
says some cute crap he does say cute
crap what do you guys think of Garrett
are you still thinking of his Instagram
scandal or have you moved past and
you're just living in the now of the
show let me know
can you see past it okay can you see
through the trees can you frolic through
them and see through what is that praise
I'm really ranting now okay drink every
time Garrett's mom is not messing around
it's no holds barred with Garrett's mom
no no holds bar needs a wrestler name
she's a mother bear she's very strong
for her family she protects her family
to the end or everything to me
I love her don't know why I'm going down
that scroll again you never feel as
complete as a man is being surrounded
with the people that you love and that
you're falling in love with the look in
her eyes when he said he was falling in
love with Becca the look said it all but
she said more and then his family got a
little confusing don't drink every time
they Cheers there was so many cheers
heard it was like a chorus little
brother want to go have a chat with your
sister and then Garrett's sister did she
have an accent what do you guys think
tell me I couldn't tell it just breaks
my heart what you want gone through oh
my gosh this poor woman I've been here
okay I'd like that have you guys been
here when you get so high-pitched cuz
you're trying not to cry routine like
that get my family very seriously
very seriously of course we know that
Garrett was married before and so his
family seems very apprehensive because
they did not like that woman he was
married to you can tell they felt that
she took Garrett to a dark place and now
they want Garrett to be in a light place
and they could plant all tomatoes not
get sunlight and girls tell me what you
guys thought of Garrett's hometown date
did it make you like Garrett more or
less and what did you think of his
wonderful mother Barbara very seriously
I love the hometown dates because the
families are always a little cookie now
we are with Jason and every week Jason
gives us a different movie look this
week we were back to his Wall Street
look his like long wintry coat and his
very gelled hair cuz we're in Buffalo
New York with your wings you cheese or
ranch no ranch in Buffalo and we're
eatin wings why does she always end up
in a bar setting with Jason's spare to
Jason we've always got to do these
activities and bars neat Wang is that
one happy hour and it's just too casual
but Becca says she quote has the best
time when she's with Jason and guys what
do you think about Becca's analysis of
the guys at this point this week I got
confused she is always saying that
Garrett makes her smile non-stop that
she is the best time with Jason that her
heart sees Blake's heart that Colton is
so like it's too much greatness I can't
distinguish but what I do know is she's
in love with Blake the feelings are
reciprocated so when she says she is the
best time with Jason I already know that
she said last week but she's in love
with Blake so is it the best time the
best Becca you said that you want
honesty and we want honesty from you you
say you're not gonna lie a lot I'm not
gonna lie joy not going so are you lying
to these guys
I don't think she's lying but I am
confused tell me what you guys think
Jason says that he was so guarded I
didn't protect her and his mom is saying
feel like he's been guarded for so long
why is Jason guarded did I miss Jason
talking about a previous relationship
this happened a lot tonight it was like
Jason was guarded and Blake had been
broken or smushed and Colton was broken
and I don't know I guess I missed these
guys talking about their past
relationships they only remember
Garrett's divorce how do you know you
can't define okay also Jason's mom has
definitely seen the show because Jason's
like I'm in love with her and I know
she's in love with me too and his mom is
like that's his mom rewinding in her
head Jason man says he is ready to
propose to Becca that she is the person
he wants to spend forever with oh my god
I did not see this coming I think that
Becca is just so generally great that
especially in this environment these
guys are really falling hard for Becca I
mean it is intense so I do to see in
Becca's defense she's got a lot of
emotions to deal with okay and then we
have I don't know why I saying that I
also don't know why we didn't know that
Becca was calling Blake her mountain man
that guy said her down man did you guys
know this Becca comes up blaka
always have a celebrity name Becca Blake
blaka the cake beefcake Blake is a
beefcake anyway and then we go to
Blake's high school whoa you guys we
found out some really serious stuff on
this outing to Blake's high school we
found out just how close everything was
in his world he said he's from a small
town we remember we learned last week
that his mom had an affair I believe
with his coach and who we find out his
mom worked at his high school
unclear if the coach was also at the
high school but
really digs in and reveals to Becca that
while he was in high school and his mom
was also working there and his sister
went there there was a school shooting
at his high school which is just crazy
and it so makes me sad that so many
people growing up in America today have
probably had this experience I really
want to peel back the layers and get to
know black on a deeper level how much
deeper can we get with Blake Blake has
told us so much about its himself his
family how much deeper do we get with
Blake what was crazy about meeting Lakes
family is like I'm wondering who's who
I'm sorry I don't think we really found
out correct me if I'm wrong let me know
in the comments but I'm like his mom's
here I think this guy's his dad is his
mom still with the guys she had the
affair with he's that guy here in the
room
can someone acknowledge it we found out
about the affair last week and I'm
thinking oh my gosh when we go home to
meet his family this is gonna be crazy
and it seemingly wasn't acknowledged and
maybe it wasn't acknowledged because
Blake didn't tell his mom like hey mom
and dropped a bomb about you on national
TV last week I don't know heard the
cries the panic attacks and his mom
reveals that Blake was so broken from a
recent relationship that he was having
panic attacks
what relationship I think confused
onca Colden we're in Colorado for Colton
- didn't have to travel too far and we
are introduced to some kids that
Colton's nonprofit works with and it was
very sweet I think that Colton has a
really really good heart you guys he
spent a lot of time on this charity my
dad I have a player type relation that
talks about his family he said his
relationship with his dad is like a
coach one that made me kind of sad that
stuck out to you guys I don't know I
want I mean I get it I guess but I want
it to be like it had one I could see a
husband a life partner a teammate I'm
falling for him Becca is just really
talking up her feelings for Colton but
we know she's in love like I just
haven't told him just like Blake's mom's
thing wasn't acknowledged this episode I
needed there to be a reason from Becca
as to why if she knows she's in love
with Blake that she's still into these
other guys like she said at one point I
mean I can see futures is all of them
but that's like saying well I'm in love
with this guy and then I met this guy
who seems cool well yeah I mean you
could see a future with that guy you
could be like oh I could live with you
versus dying alone but you're in love
with the other guy are you guys confused
do you think that the Blake thing seems
just skyrockets ahead of everybody else
skyrockets wasn't the right word there
but you know what I'm saying let me know
help me find clarity I need you just
like back in our girlfriends need a
mimosa oh my gosh they brought Tia and
Kendall and Sienna and Caroline I think
that's everyone oh and Becca the other
Becca they brought them back to talk to
Becca and they came for the spa date
earlier this season and now they're back
for more mimosas and Girl Talk all we
women do is talk over mimosas we can't
have a conversation without a mimosa
anyway does it seem like it really could
happen like you're really gonna be
yeah so obviously these women have had
to come back because Colton is still
here and we know Tia dated Colton and
that's gonna come to a head and it does
and we talk for a second right now yeah
did you guys see that coming we saw it
coming Tia is chewing on your cheek like
it's nobody's business went back talking
about Colton
oh my god obviously this is like hard
for me and I'm like nervous to even have
to talk to you about this right now but
and Tia tells Beca she's got to talk to
her and she pulls her outside ah away
from the girls and they have a
conversation and Tia says that she saw
his feelings for Colton and that she
didn't think he'd make it this far and
Beckett says all she wants his honesty
and fall off and that's true all season
she's been saying she just wants honesty
and she is said not gonna lie
and even though I'm confused I do think
Becca really wants honesty and we know
where this is gonna go don't we did you
guys know at this point that so before
Colton get sent home we've got to have
an absolutely iconic moment of
awkwardness
Chris Harrison reappears haven't seen
him in a minute we get some shaky camera
work as Colton seemingly asks Chris for
advice are you saying you were worried
about being intimate with Becca at this
point yeah so Chris Harrison giving
Colton advice on the fantasy suites was
so generic and so awkward and Chris
really powered through and for this
week's on the journey with JC JC has not
seen this part of the episode so he's
gonna come in and give me advice not
knowing what Chris Harrison said it
we're gonna see if it's on par with the
awkwardness of their conversation JC ok
JC what advice would you give a guy on
how to behave in fantasy suites I would
check the prices on the minibar oh
definitely good to check their
conditioning make sure it doesn't get
too cold yeah
yeah I would check to see the waters
free like don't buy those $5 bottles
like Wow expensive JC is just apparently
all about minding your budget but here
is a fantasy and the journey includes
you know making sure that you're
planning for your 401k apparently many
bars are overpriced aren't they want to
rip off they hate you wear than they can
because they know you want those M&Ms
mmm
Chris Harrison didn't show up a lot in
his episode but the moments he was here
he made worthwhile so the rose ceremony
happens and I gotta give one little
knock to my boy Blake what was he
wearing
what was that Blake usually absolutely
nails his fashion game and this week he
looks like he was taking somebody to
prom what's that red bow tie to match a
corsage or what are we doing here
there were a lot of primary colors in
the rose ceremony they were just in like
blues and blacks and I'm like the red of
the Roses it was weird
Blake in his weird tux gets the first
rose because Becca's in love with him
and then Colton gets sent home oh you
guys the luck on Colton's face it was
like when Becca said Garrett's name he
was like it looks like he was gonna fall
over first second didn't it and that's a
big guy a topple over it was rough I do
think Colton was surprised I think he
thought he was gonna stick around and
Becca was surprisingly stone-faced were
you surprised by her reaction or were
you thinking to yourself of course she's
not gonna because she's nothing like let
me know and then I started to think
maybe cold was just tired maybe that's
why he looks like he was gonna fall over
maybe it was a long night cuz he gets in
the limo he just closes his eyes right
away it's like is the processing or is
he falling asleep you know
tough call but we left Colton all our
love to Colton so again I'm a little bit
all over the place because Becca said
she did see a future with Colton and she
sees a future with the other guys and
she's in love with Blake so why I was
quoting the one to send home I needed
more explanation Becca I'm not gonna lie
I want honesty alright so that was this
episode were you guys surprised that
Colton was the one who was sent home let
me know who are you loving at this point
I really like Jason and I really like
Blake next week on The Bachelorette
I want to talk about the promo for next
episode it looked so good again these
guys have fallen so hard for Becca and
what's not to love she's great but Jason
and Garrett and Blake all seem really
intense powerful things I'm not the guy
that blazes heart underlying I'm scared
I'm the kind of guy who looks for reason
to sustain
and then Oh Becca is crying and we have
learned this season and it takes a lot
for Becca to Christ
shouldn't cry when she sent Colt know
him you know it takes a lot she's been
through some stuff so she doesn't
crazily and she says I'm doing to him
what Ari did what are you did to me I'm
processing it Becca I'm not falling
asleep don't think I'm buying a sleep
back I'm just thinking about what you've
said and what you've done I am wearing
purple today because purple is a regal
color and today I interviewed a queen
Rachel Lindsay former Bachelorette was
here in our ET studio and that interview
is up at et online.com now she reveals
her wedding plans yes she has a date in
mind and she is move forward on wedding
planning oh my god check it out and she
gives us her thoughts on what she would
have done about the Garrett thing ah you
know Rachel always has a hot take so
thank you guys so much for being here
and powering through whilst I was
drinking red wine instead of the usual
Rose ale and forgetting through the
confusion of course I always want to
know what you think of this episode as
we are winding down who will Becca
choose mmm I love you so much babe so
Garrett said this wine is so bad
god I miss my rosy